no British politician has been more
associated with the push to get Britain
out of the EU than my guest here in
Brussels the u-clip MEP Nigel Faraj
punchy assertive always controversial he
more than anyone else set the tone for
the brexit campaign but at what cost
isn't Britain now a more divided angrier
nation than it's been for many years
[Music]
Nigel Farage welcome to conflict zone
thank you you said that you want to help
get a decent deal for Britain in its
negotiations with the EU I want to use
my position particularly with the
European media to make sure that French
and German Belgian voters put huge
pressure on their MEP s to say come on
let's have a common-sense trade deal why
would they listen to you after you've
insulted them so much of oh I've never
insulted the European people not once
not once in twenty your about what about
the European Council President former
president who had the charisma of a damp
row come on what about him come on what
am i hit you know something in Prime
Minister's Questions every single
Wednesday things a lot ruder than that
get said go to the Australian Parliament
what gets said there's unrepeatable on a
program like yours
he's got Cheney insisted it is now I
don't used it you got you know to those
how do they do something it was a
complete off-the-cuff comment I hadn't
pre-planned it it just happened but the
point is that joshing about with a man
who'd been appointed on a salary big of
an Obama that nobody had ever heard of
struck me as fair comment look let's get
is your [ __ ] is your wench let's just
get one thing straight it asks you a
question okay I have over the years
worked for French companies I've had
businesses in Italy I've married a
German I am NOT anti-european in any way
at all but I think that what now
masquerades as Europe is a mistake and
needs changing so do I think there are
people out there in Europe that listen
to what I have to say yes I do but this
is what this was your post referendum
pitch yeah to the European Parliament
this was last year I know that virtually
none of you have ever done a proper job
in your life quite I worked in business
quite or indeed ever created a job quite
right and you think grass bottle endears
odd to them let me tell it on the other
bridge for Britain to get a big deal as
a Rosanna hang on well yes actually I do
so here's the point the United Kingdom
has just voted to leave the European
Union
there's a debate when you said this
there's a debate here four days later so
I get up to speak and 400 of them start
booing and jeering and I thought as they
still do and I thought they'll do you
know for us as they still do well if
they want to do that so I thought let
them have a piece of it what I am saying
here is this it would be a bad thing for
the peoples of Europe if the political
class of Europe willfully go for a bad
deal with Britain because they want to
punish us they want to discourage other
people leaving the club and I do not
think that across much of Europe that
the political elites are held in any
high degree of regard so you can
certainly accuse me of attacking the
European elites but my goodness me
they've given me some - all right hear
this from the German car manufacturers
you told everyone in Britain of course
the Germans will never allow tariffs to
be slapped on their car exports to brick
they wouldn't want it they wouldn't want
it okay so what did Chancellor Merkel
tell the world she said the internal
cohesion of the EU would come before
defending German exports to the UK the
association of car manufacturer says the
future of the EU is more important than
short-term exports would you know what
this actually plays into my hands even
more this gives me an eve this gives me
an even bigger card that I thought I had
to play because here is my virtual card
that's what they're telling you oh no no
no wait a Cajun card
oh come on the relationship between big
business big banks and big politics is
what it is they don't want things to
change they like the status quo the way
that it is but I bet you that if we went
to a bar in Munich this evening and met
some German car workers and had this
conversation what they care about are
their jobs what they care about a cars B
maybe but the bosses are gonna go your
route just for that I'm not talking to
the bosses I'm talking to the European
they're the ones who make the decisions
want to tell you something actually when
they're backing more ground wrong wrong
and let me tell you why you're wrong we
are due to leave the European Union at
the end of March 19 okay the European
elections take place a few weeks later
what I want to try to do is no guarantee
of success
what
want to try to do is to make sure that
those MEP s who are up for re-election
are asked by their electorates are you
going to vote for sensible trade deal
are you going to vote for our jobs
because you know one thing's for certain
there are 1.3 million people in Germany
whose jobs rely on exports to the UK
market and they're prepared to take the
hit this is what they're Jenny do you
local is tell you in your heart don't
you take seriously what they say to you
because you're talking about a political
class who I've got no respect for at all
I let me ask you this you've been ruling
for question time honest cuz they been
given though Angela Merkel still has
even though I'm polls pretty much in her
favor I'd any much in how I do not
believe that you may be right I may be
wrong I do not believe that if we went
directly to those 1.3 million people be
they in pharmaceuticals be they in
engineering be they in car manufacture
if we ask there's 1.3 million people
whose jobs depend on trade with the UK
is a trade deal a priority for you over
and above maintaining the EU as it is I
think I don't what the answer but why is
it you can't understand what they're
saying to you they're saying to you that
actually something matters more to them
than it does to you do you know
something twenty really matters to the
Jewish movement jasmine for twenty years
every single political party virtually
every national newspaper every
broadcaster every trade union and every
business organization told me I was
wrong and that none of them would ever
listen to me and we're just about to
come into a general election where half
of that group now support Britain
leaving the European Union
you can change opinion yeah and the
country is just as divided as ever on it
we had the latest YouGov poll which came
after Teresa may announce the election
forty-four percent believe brexit is
Right forty four percent believe it's
wrong and twelve percent
well actually I've seen cells yes they
need devising polls
yes missus in it I saw two big polls
last month one 69 percent of 170 percent
accepting the result and what are the
government to get on with it
it may accept the result but this is
forty four percent who they're on level
pegging besides you think that brexit
right beside you think I don't either as
I say if you ask people up
of those who didn't agree with Breck sit
there's a significant number of them who
are Democrats accept the result and
accept they were going to get on with it
and you could argue if you talk about
division the division was there way
before the referendum which is why it
came to a head in the first place
it's not more about trade you came back
from the states in January you said you
were you were beside yourself with
excitement you've been told Trump camp
yes but you've been told by the Trump
camp that you could get a trade deal
done and dusted your words in 90 days
yeah the Trump team you said was
offering Britain a great gift not just
for business you said not just for trade
not just for investment but actually to
strengthen our hand in negotiating with
the European Union didn't take long for
that to crumble away did it because
because the British government can't
play they're not allowed to you see what
London Times reported a week ago as a
nonsense story oh is it not really stor
that the White House had said there's a
realization of trade deal with the EU
was more important to US interests than
a post brexit deal I know the Trump team
I don't believe that for one moment but
why don't you accept you've been stiffed
but while I tell you what I do accept
and it's this that I think there was
genuine shock amongst the American
administration that the British
government was not in a position to
accept their generous offer and to sit
round the table and to start negotiation
and in a sense we get to the core of why
the EU has been bad for Britain in a
21st century global economy as a result
of being part of this 19th century
concept called a customs union
we are banned barred forbidden from
making our own trade deals anywhere else
okay you've made the point but but the
u.s. a stiffed you the Trump
administration stood last December the
incoming free the incoming Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross was telling
countries to use brexit to steal
business from Britain he actually told
me actually dreadful of course of course
any chain that's a friend of no not
somebody queuing up to offer blame the
great trail he was giving him speaking
of the business seminar look in business
all the time what you seek you think
these people is your fragile sedative
advantage do I think that Trump
instinctively believes that Britain is a
friend yes I do
100 percent unlike the
the procedure and he goes I do anything
for Britain that isn't directly in his
ingest the British government say yes
wait anyway if the British government
say yes and they've said no they said
I'm very sorry but that man mr. Yonker
no one ever voted for him but that man
mr. younger in Brussels says we're not
allowed to negotiate with you
it rather sums up why we have to leave
this Union a trade deal with America
done and dusted in 90 days it's not
gonna happen is it what if the British
government said yes to it was not going
to ha EU bosses have you ever negotiated
a trade deal no I haven't no you haven't
but so you have no idea what's involved
but I tell you what NHS anyone I have
done unlike most people in this building
I have put together business
propositions deals ship stuff all over
the world I actually have got a cities
of a trade deal you've never done of
course and isn't even ever time thanks
to you isn't it wonderful
when I hear people telling me it could
take five years ten years Australia I
didn't say that I just said Australia I
just didn't know what its involved what
I didn't want to do those well you've
got will you can do what you like in
life and sadly the British government
and I think we should be ignored the EU
I think we should have gone in straight
in to a trade negotiation we didn't do
say I'm sorry about it why aren't you
standing again for Parliament in
Westminster because it's eighth time
lucky could be eight time modulates very
interesting a lot of commentators like
you say that but I mean do just bear one
thing in mind which might be useful for
the list for the viewers of this program
and that is that in 2014 I led a
political party to winning a national
election something that had not been
done since 1906 by a party that wasn't
labour or the conservative so they go
and a party it's now in tatters because
then I wouldn't say it's in tatters I
would say what's happened to it
is it's been so successful so
dramatically successful I mean two years
ago in the last general election we had
a British Prime Minister David Cameron a
Chancellor George Osborne calling you
Kip negative backward little Englanders
now we have a prime minister mrs. may
who on the face of it has taken on the
whole matter and now you have your
party's biggest funder ex funder who
says the party is run by a team of
circus clowns stuffed with people who
use it as a piggy bank rather than a
vehicle for political change come on
we've got the party's falling apart
we've got lots and lots of donors all of
whom oh this man doesn't matter anymore
look what he does cause he daren't banks
it doesn't matter anymore
everybody LS every though I could every
single one of our big donors is a
self-made entrepreneur this is your
achievement talking my Trump they say
what they face is your achieve me
talking about a team of circus clowns
you built it up you aligned it can you
so signed off on the policies they seem
a circus clown you think of a political
party in the West in modern times that's
be more successful than you get because
I come you know I've got a single seat
we were shyster you haven't got a single
seat in West Boise change British
history so maybe your times over which
it's time to just leave the scene I
didn't come into politics for a career I
came into politics to try and change
things and boy we've done that and mr.
banks who was going to stand as your
candidate yeah platters decided isn't
because the party he says is going in
entirely the wrong direction and he
doesn't want to wage a war on the Muslim
religion which he thinks the party is
intent on doing well c'mon eat what he
actually said can't even hold on to
somebody like that what is what he
actually said was he wants a total ban
on all Muslims integration which has
gone further than the back look self
mate I'm just telling you what he says
self-made individual he doesn't want to
war against them without an order why no
no I don't never have done it oh he's
got the part I'm glad I was leader of
this party he clearly thinks the party's
leader of this party for a very very
long time and I was very careful that we
didn't align with the gate builders ISM
people like that who wanted a war in
Islam I've never wanted that but they
and the other Euroskeptic parties aren't
doing well you pledge to help them as
well didn't you there you thought the
big big Euroskeptic wave there is that
oh it's happening look at Norfolk over
defeated in Austria get builders
defeated in the nails the AFD go down if
we'd sat here five years ago and I'd
said to you that a presidential
candidate from the Austrian freedom
party would come within a whisker of
winning the Austrian presidency you'd
have laughed at me euro scepticism is on
the march everywhere and it comes in
money shown in 2002 we have marine lepen
sir
father actually make it to the first
round as number two and we did honey we
did and he got 22 percent whatever it
was it was a slightly freakish situation
that got in there but actually yeah so
it's so it's not so unheard of go back
to yourself so I know no but they don't
look in a very good state now and she
doesn't have in a position to win an
election in France well I tell you what
she I tell you what she's not gonna get
22 percent she had a lot more than that
she matched nah gonna win is she it
looks unlikely but you never know after
all break so despite your XE was never
gonna happen despite your everywhere
that she has shifted the center ground
in France forever you said forever
that's a big claim in politics anybody
turns anything forever imposed by I you
see I think look I think what were
actually witnessing is the European
projects dying before our eyes it
doesn't work there's very little
residual love for it yeah I accept there
are very powerful institutions that's
still back and support the status quo
but yeah I honestly the life of this
project is now time limited that's a
that's a big claim but then I don't know
but then that's your speciality is big
claims and getting it right and getting
and getting noticed no I'm getting it
right
I'm Andrew with Andrew Wigmore who was
head of communications for levy you he
said you all looked at the chump
campaign which was peddling all sorts of
nonsense getting massive traction and
you took your cue from them didn't you
he put it outrageously provocative
tweets and they were all immigration led
so when it comes to the bad stuff we
totally took the Trump rulebook and
applied it here in Britain and we
quickly destroyed work he might have
done but wasn't that your philosophy too
yeah but to be honest the Trump campaign
didn't get going until the referendum
was over so the time lag here doesn't
really bet but the messages were
deliberately inflammatory weren't no I
tell you what the messages which a lot
of people condemned is only what the
media rose to the king and you've got
extra publicity for you stirred it up
though I'm good at doing that yes I'm
good with you belong good a delegate um
no I'm gonna get a good debate going I
wouldn't deny that Robin you've stirred
it out outrageously provocative tweets
that's when he talked about well if I
tell you something you get it you look
you look at my Twitter profile my
facebook profile you can go back for the
last five years there is very little as
an objective journalist that you would
say was outrageous pushing the edges of
how bad this was into debate yes I
joined last year you said the
possibility of attacks by migrants like
those that are taking place in Cologne
would be the nuclear bomb of the
referendum I think they were in the end
I have to say I think which was which
was deemed to be outrageous scare me I
think I think if I'm if I'm I look back
on that referendum and there were there
were lots of factors that led to a
brexit vote despite a massive
establishment attempt to get us to vote
remain I do think what mrs. Merkel did
made a very big difference of the
British referendum when I genuine you
mean that
let's just stay if we made with some of
the techniques that you use Aaron banks
said we picked fights with just about
everyone and fed off the phony outrage
of the mainstream no woman loves that
was one of your tactics as well he's
read if you read that book the bad boys
are brexit written by our own banks what
you will see 20 or 30 times in that book
are me having big arguments with him and
Andy wit ball so your dissociating
yourself from that I did not support
everything they did during the
referendum
what about picking of the fights with
just about everyone you enjoyed that no
I don't believe in doing that you know
feeding off the phony outrage you know
what you can do that sometimes obviously
but you like your Obama quote for
instance last November when you when you
called him what was in a loathsome
creature
yeah it's about that's what you've gone
gratuitous insult wasn't it just
designed to get you somewhat ugly he
insulted the whole British people he
didn't solid the British nation for
eight years he insulted them he said
we'd be at the back of the queue beside
inside he looked out it's not insulting
sit down his nose of this and he saw
Germany as his primary ally in Europe he
believed in the United States of Europe
and that's a reason that lonely my low
leadership Merkel that's the reason to
go alone some keys that's borderline
racist isn't it sorry isn't it
to call him a loathsome creatures
waterline racist is why John Woodcock
MEP says disgusting life is like clear
racist under please explain why because
would you have said that about anybody
else yes have you I've said
according to you have you have mass
according to you I don't were anybody
else a loathsome creature oh I've had
all sorts of things here the people the
idea the idea that you can't make a
comment about someone because they're
female or they're Jewish
although whatever is nonsense the other
thing that the other thing that mr.
Wiggins said was that foreigners had to
be in the firing line pretty much all
the time the outrageous tweets were
about enough links to do with me all
right
nothing to do with me and and look what
did I do in that referendum campaign I
started that referendum campaign in July
15 all right before everybody else that
even got mobilized and my referendum
campaign was about touring the country
about speaking to pack townhall meetings
about motivating and mobilizing people
who genuine generally don't vote to get
out and vote no you did it by pressing I
did here but I did it by saying we want
our country back
we want our borders I'm pressing with my
pride back we won our place in the world
back we want a relationship with
Commonwealth back I hold the other side
project fear jealous of you were
pressing I fear that once you I disagree
completely why I think next isn't as
some of the messages I use concerned
about the amount of crime being
committed in the UK by foreign criminals
that's pressing the film whose message
is that this is vote leave dot EU baby
well that was your side I'm in the
brexit I campaign that was we've got you
I led the you kick campaign yes all
right
but you were part of my letter e I
supported leave dot yes exactly
as in D you didn't dissociate this I
mean these mess has indeed did 18
different political organizations
including the new Communist Party of
Great Britain all right did I support
all the take your friends careful JIT
height in Heights with it politics
referendum strange bedfellows did I
support everything leave dot EU seven
did no I did not but you didn't come out
and repudiate it did you
well exam one of campaigns on all sorts
of people doing things I mean I was the
thing that maybe the most angry actually
wasn't leave da see you I think that
maybe the most angry was what was was
what vote leave did with this ridiculous
three hundred and fifty million a week
figure yeah maybe week week it's really
upset me I didn't say and I said
i sat down with Michael Gove in a
private room and said drop it
yeah but he didn't but he do didn't come
out and go public about the mistake
which you said this way until the day of
your fights a day after your fighting
enemy you don't shoot your own side on
the back you you're either interested in
truth or you're not you don't know you
knew use was untrue I that's which is
why I fought so hard you were prepared
to let it stand in public did you have a
thousand opportunities to repudiate it I
chose not to you chose not to you don't
shoot your own side of them even for the
sake of honesty the British public are
worth honesty I tell you what tell what
I said that was wrong I'm telling you
this is what you're doing who's new what
you're doing news that this was wrong it
was let it stand was a silly figure you
let it stand
I never defended it you let it stand I
was very easily wounded by the flag
because you can't shoot your inside in
the back otherwise otherwise the story
is division what do you care about most
your insight or the truth winning the
most important constitutional behalf for
300 years in the United Kingdom so the
end justifies the means does it you took
what I did wrong I'm just saying the
other who let it but I usually let it go
it's very interesting you refused to
repudiate it at the moment so far in
this interview you haven't come up with
one thing that I said that was it out
here at all wrong but you can I'm all I
didn't I didn't say you were either
inaccurate or wrong I'm said saying you
refused to repudiate this you know what
I'm saying I refuse to do you know what
I refuse to divide the leave camp yes
you refuse to stand up for the truth in
public because the public weren't worth
it I didn't divide the leave camp
weren't worth it were they and it was a
minor risk you compared compared to the
lives of the other side it was a minor
risk do you think I mean you got your
way Britain is leaving the EU but the
things that Aaron banks and the other
people in the levy you confessed to
which was the picking of fights the
outrageously provocative tweets the
insults has it made Britain a nastier
country you think well that wasn't a and
again you know you you've got to stop
judge you've got to stop judging me but
what other people say judging I'm asking
you I'm asking you the question has it
made Britain a nastier place I don't get
that I think during the campaign it was
and I think the immediate aftermath was
pretty bloody
I've been signs like leave the EU no
more polish vermin t-shirts and say yes
we won now send them back okay so do you
think the abusers will of one side I'm
not saying it was but I'm asking you and
not us about the abuse that came from
your side what about the abuse that came
towards me or is that have no interest
you yeah but I talk to other people
about the abuse they give you and the
methods they use I'm talking to you
about your methods you know very well
what I'm trying to just were yeah but
it's all presented in well it's all
presented as a one way debate and
actually one of course I'm talking to
you about what you do love them in your
side eye to eye then about their cyber
mates after the referendum I think there
was a very heightened feeling in the
United Kingdom things have calmed down
massively since then so what happens if
it all goes wrong I mean we haven't even
started the negotiation you you said in
2015 you said in 2015 at the Oxford
Union none of us knows what the risks
are if we leave the European Union none
of us knows what the risks are if we
stay in the you that's right so we were
left to just you know take your bravado
and your what it's very simple and
you're sure instead of it very simple
we're left to do that very simple you
could never predict the future exactly
whatever side of the referendum or a to
you as you said you UK anyone that
thinks he knows the future should be
retired because I should have made a
fortune you know and the real question
with that referendum was should we be
responsible as a nation with its own
identity for making the key decisions
that determine our future and whether we
get them right or get them wrong
genuinely once every four or five years
have the chance to hold to account the
people who took those decisions or do we
think our future better to be a small
voice as part of a bigger new state and
I've been as you know objective about
that as I possibly can be that's what
the referendum was about and what we
opted for not by a massive march of what
we opted for was making our own
decisions and steering our own ship and
that I believe to be right in all
circumstances all right we're coming to
the end of our time just before I let
you go March the 9th you were seeing
going into the echo
dorium London home to the WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange a reporter asks
you later whether you'd seen him in the
building you said you couldn't remember
what you'd been doing is the building
has that short-term memory loss going
for you these days you're getting
treatment for it yeah I got a request I
got a request actually through a media
organization but I do a bit of work from
4:00 to go and meet him and you know
what as you well know if somebody
interesting says they want to meet you
you go meet them about in some strategic
mayhem with rotting absolutely I promise
you nothing at all thank you for us and
good to have you home complex on thank
you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]